the the role of cars and in trucks you
know in in our system in our economy
is massive uh actually much bigger than
what um we care to to realize and you
know you you probably
either travel with your own vehicle or
taken an Uber or
um you know order a delivery of
something only in the last you know
three days probably
hundreds of miles were driven just for
you as an individual and so the impact
that transportation and vehicles have on
our economy is enormous
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're talking about
mobility and the way that technology is
interacting with consumers in the
mobility space meet eleran extend the
co-founder and CEO of Ravine AI elegon
has dedicated his work in the past 10
years to digitizing the automotive and
transportation sectors before founding
Ravine eligon was head of new business
development at Shell's digital Ventures
unit in London investing in incubating
new businesses that could leverage
Shell's Global footprint of retail
locations for the benefit of fleets
motorists and smart cities prior to that
Elion served as the CEO of fairpilot.com
a startup using machine learning to help
taxi and Uber drivers find their next
passenger by predicting demand patterns
in local areas Elion is an MBA from
London Business School and is the proud
father of two boys and one adorable girl
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for taking time out of your busy
schedule to be here how are you
I'm well thanks for having me and I'm
excited to talk to you about Ravine AI
as co-founder and CEO previously you've
you've been in this in this space
Automotive space for a while previously
uh previously with shell and with Fair
pilot and so I'm looking forward to
understanding from you better sort of
your entrance to to the integration of
AI computer vision and and and
Automotives in general and and why do
you do what you do and so thank you very
much for being here
absolutely I'm looking forward to it
well tell me just a little bit about
yourself and and why are you so excited
and passionate about
cars Ai and the intersection
well um those who know me
um know by now I'm kind of half British
um half Israeli I'll spend most of my
career in the UK
um but the way I could have ended up in
entrepreneurship is completely
coincidental uh my education comes from
finance and business I did my MBA in
London business school and I went on to
Consulting strategy and then somehow
ended up in a position with shadow
um the Energy company they're trying to
monetize on new business
we looked at ourselves and figured that
we have hundreds of thousands of
customers and in fact more than 25
million drivers daily
driving through our gas stations and we
all sell them just boil products and
coffees I sell a lot of coffees in fact
shell sells more coffee than Starbucks
so it's a fun fact
whoa okay
right and you know it it comes obviously
from the fact that we have this captive
audience which is massive and they
happen to drive a car when they drive in
and we thought okay what could what can
we offer them
um other than coffee
and we started brainstorming ideas and
then we ended up kind of as you do
um investing in companies that have all
these cool Solutions and products I
ended up as a CEO for some of these uh
some of these products and some of these
companies one of them was fair pilot
that was targeting professional drivers
like Uber drivers and Lyft drivers and
trying to sell them a software that
helps them orientate around town and
optimize between the different ride
hailing Services because they never know
exactly when to turn on the Uber what to
turn on the list and that was a service
that that quite resonated with at least
a lot uh the the london-based driver
Community uh we spun that out and I went
back to Shell I was looking for the new
idea and Raven kind of came up because
we thought okay these drivers are coming
in and out of gas stations can we
actually film those cars
and tell something about the cars to
those drivers we could tell the example
that they've got rust they have to take
care of because the rain rainy season is
starting in the UK it's kind of always
the way they season
um but uh but that was one use case and
the other one would be tires that need
replacement because they're worn out uh
or something that is just wrong in your
vehicle and you want to know Ben yeah
you're saying you know there's captive
audience that's that's you know the
first you know aha Insight that you've
had that you already have all these
people coming in how do you provide more
services that will actually give them
value one you know example you gave was
coffee and now you're saying that you
can actually leverage some some
technology to to passively
you know integrating to sort of you know
their current situation maybe offer them
something and it makes a lot of sense I
mean how many times do we actually go to
a mechanic to check on our tires and
probably by if if we if we get a
response that we need to change it's
probably long overdue because we don't
know how we don't have the trigger to go
and check ourselves right
correct
and then you and then you you know
that's the starting point that's the
interesting thing about being an
entrepreneur and I guess you've seen
this yourself and uh with so many other
guests that you gotta have a starting
point right but then once you dive in
you suddenly realizes this whole world
of
opportunity once you look at in my case
vehicle inspections you realize that the
vehicle is actually
very expensive asset in fact for many
household it's the second most expensive
asset they'll ever own wow yeah and
um and yet this asset unlike the house
is always out signs
it's always exposed to the elements it's
always exposed to this random bicycle
that could run into it it's always
exposed to an autonomous car that goes
off peace right
um and so you kind of realize that every
second or so a car gets damaged Maybe
and the cost of replacing uh part the
cost of repairing the cost of the
vehicle being off the road is enormous
yup sure it's a war okay so that gots us
going and I met with my co-founder uh
Roman seller who's a a scientific guy a
much more kind of into the tech world
than I did at the time RB is a PhD in
computer vision he's got a terrific
story he's actually one of the first
people that um designs speed cameras for
the police wow okay so we have to think
next hours when he was 15 yeah at 15. oh
15 year old uh dude from kaifa
uh doing his first degree as you do
in computer science and that's your
project that was his project incredible
I love it now you started mentioning a
bunch of different use cases for this
intersection of Technology Ai and
computer vision and cars how do you how
do you decide where to focus right I
mean a lot of these are consumer facing
you have to it's not just getting the
get doing the inspection but it's also
the action that that proceeds at your
interaction with the customer so how do
you now decide which solution is most
applicative to be focused on
right so that's when you step back and
you kind of use your Consulting skills
and you you think about the market size
and where you think there is room to to
empty and actually it took us a while to
figure out what were the exact verticals
and use cases we wanted to focus on
uh but we ended up uh with three major
use cases the first one is fleets and
car rental where there's a lot of
transition and handoffs of vehicles and
we want to give a snapshot to the owner
which is The Fleets on how well the
driver has been handling the vehicle
that was one and we got some customer
base there the Second Use case was used
car assessment every time you sell a car
you're trying to buy a used car that's a
whole kind of
black box that you need to figure out
and we've chose to go into that space
and because we realized that some of our
scanners could shed light into the
condition of the vehicle for an
unprofessional buying right and you know
this goes along and this goes along with
with what you were saying before that
this is the second most the second
biggest asset for for most households
and so you would imagine that they would
have a lot of great tools to make good
decisions especially when it comes to
valuing a purchase or a sell right this
is a really big deal
absolutely and when you when you come to
think about the process today you invest
a little bit kind of research up front
before you pick a vehicle to
um go for your pick a vehicle to
actually go and investigate sir right
and it only gets to the in-depth
inspection
when you're well it's almost too late
and you're already invested in the
process and you kind of start you know
you start thinking about like why do I
need like it's not a problem you know
this this vehicle okay it has a bit of
rust it has a bit of damage I don't care
um I just want to buy it and that's
because you don't do enough grease you
don't have enough tools
to research the car Rock Run and what we
do
with Raven is we give more tools for
ordinary people
to look at a vehicle remotely before
they actually emotionally invest and
invest their time in NFC in committing
to it and so what what is sort of the
impact that this has had so far is this
product already live and people are
interacting with it is this making a an
impact already
absolutely so you know the on the fleet
size on the fleet side we've been uh
live with uh with different companies
around the world I mean looking at the
professional driver just to give an
example uh we have a client in New York
uh called buggy TLC and they're renting
our renting cars day in day out to Uber
and less drivers we've seen the
accountability going up and level of
damage on the vehicles coming down
thanks to using the tool so that's been
an amazing saving again not only in
dealing damage
but also in the speed and utilization of
their Suites interesting uh in the you
know in the in the in the used car space
uh we have Partnerships uh like with uh
car Global that operates uh used car
markets across North America they've
also become a strategic investor and you
can start seeing how this tool kind of
saves time and adds transparency to the
whole transaction
fascinating and so going back a little
bit to sort of your entrance into this
world and and deciding to focus all of
your energy on this right now why are
you so so excited about this I mean
obviously it sounds like an awesome
product it sounds like a great problem
to solve but there's a lot of different
things that one can do with with AI and
and humans why why is this sort of the
most exciting thing for you right now
look I think the the the role of cars
and in trucks you know in in our system
in our economy
is massive uh actually much bigger than
what um we care to to realize and you
know you you probably
either travel with your own vehicle or
taking an Uber or
um you know order a delivery of
something only in the last you know
three days probably
hundreds of miles were driven just for
you as an individual and so the impact
that transportation and vehicles have on
our economy is enormous and I think if
we can generate savings if we can
actually use less vehicles for more of
the society's demands
that's a major Improvement on you know
in human human life sure to me and where
do they get it where is the big step
function or is it is it on the
technology front or is it on the the way
that consumers are willing or are
understanding that they can adopt the
technology into their daily lives
because this is a pretty old idea that
we go we we purchase a vehicle you know
you're changing the way that we're
thinking through this this process or
with any inspection right not just that
so how where does sort of the bigger
step function if you had to to guess
look it's ours it's it's something
that's missed that is embedded in
different steps in the process so I'll
just give you an example you're
researching your next car online you're
buying a used car
this is another tool that helps you
filter out the bad the lemons and really
focus on the good ones that really meet
your requirements so it saves you a lot
of time
have your lung miss it you only travel
and meet the seller that knew
you feel strongly about
um and you also spend less money on
these more thorough and in you know
physical inspections
um but with that you reduce congestion
on these inspection centers so you're
kind of creating a lot of transparency
that creates in turn efficiency I'm just
talking about the used car sales sure in
the fleet side lots of savings there on
driving back and forth to get a car
estimated for repair back and forth
communication with customers that have
maybe damaged to vehicles
lots of different efficiency points once
you adopt this kind of tool how does it
actually work this inspection process
well how how do different Fleet managers
car providers purchasers what is what is
their their interaction with your
product today
so what the way we built it as a
platform that the most common use of the
platform is that you get a web tool a
web application
you can click on a link once you pick up
a car or you return a con and it opens
the camera or you're on your browser
and your thing Guided by the tool to
basically document the vehicle
using computer vision an algorithm that
we use both on the front end and also in
the cloud we can create a profile than a
vehicle and we can already identify
potential areas of problems
and so we create that report we put it
back into our system and we log it and
then the use cases then diverge a bit
because in the rental experience you'll
have a log of the condition of the
vehicle over time and a used card
setting you'll have just a snapshot of
the vehicle
um at that point in time however if you
think about this tool a few years down
the line you could start creating a
database for the vehicles of the world
really and start logging for these up
inspections as the history of that
vehicle which is also today something
pretty opaque interesting and what
happens then so you you have some
insights and you provide some
information through the inspection let's
say they're an interesting Insight right
it's a this car has a malfunction in X
or you should check out white is what
what is is this enough for them to make
a decision do they they need to take it
to a thorough in-person inspection what
is sort of the action item that you
expect a customer should do there
so if a if you're talking about a biome
of a vehicle in many cases our
inspection will be enough for them to
make the purchase decision
now that is uh typically for newer
Vehicles where you have less suspicion
of hitting hidden issues because
obviously you can't look at what you
can't see yeah
exactly now we can give an indication uh
which translates into a very tangible
outcome which is a grading of the
vehicle so today especially in the
American Market you create a used car
from one to fives huh and our algorithm
is sophisticated enough to give that
grade to a vehicle
and it would be roughly close to what
the human professional inspector would
give them that doesn't sound like it
doesn't sound like it's a significant
range giving one to five I would imagine
it would be like 1 to 20 on like 10
different parameters and and okay I'm a
little surprised
well that's a you know that first of all
the one to five is an increments of 0.1
so it's not like one two three
basically yeah
exactly so you know and that's just a
coin
it's a coin that is being used in the
used car market especially North America
and different markets of their own uh
their own grading systems which have by
the way not a perfect system but it
helps
um and so I think you know it's a big
lesson learned so this kind of tool that
just needs to plug into the terminology
at the industry is using so what we do
with a tool we basically allow a
decision to be taken much more quickly
on that vehicle
right right and if you're sort of
extrapolating this a little bit further
down the line what is your your vision
here how do you how do you grow Ravine
Ai and what what do you what are you
trying to make it to be
So Raven is really
um what topic sign is for for document
Exchange
so the idea is that everywhere that you
hand over custody on a vehicle the tool
is so seamlessly embedded in every
process and every transaction that
um it is it's becoming a stamp like a
fingerprint okay right
this is the authentic representation of
the vehicle so obviously we'll need to
add much more
um Tools around mechanical condition
electric conditions battery condition
obviously is a big theme for electric
vehicles uh but at least on the physical
status of the vehicle we can already
create a really good representation
uh which
expedites the transaction which creates
a peace of mind
poor the person who's handing off uh
responsibility and I think the use cases
will continue growing
as we see more shared Mobility
we support fleets more people changing
hands more transaction on a roadside and
although you're no longer renting from
hurt and Avis you're rented from a
neighbor
yep that made sense uh and I I think
that for me what you know what's most
exciting here is this you know the the
consumer Behavior shift and you're
really you know tapping into a pretty
Humane process that we have today and
and integrating existing technology and
and I love the the Insight that we
started with which is
this idea that both you can you you saw
full shell how you can integrate
computer vision to to come up with
interesting insights but then taking it
a step further as an entrepreneur and
say okay well we actually have this huge
ocean here of possibilities whether it's
from per private buyers sellers to Fleet
managers uh to uh to to sharing car
sharing services and so it's really
fascinating and I loved hearing about
you know your story for these past 20
minutes and I need to let you get back
to to running a company and so thank you
very much Leon this was awesome hey best
of luck Ravine AI I look forward to
using it myself in my next car purchase
or sell and best of luck
thank you coming soon